we're now joined by the former chief
whip of the conservative party mark
harper who is a supporter of rishi sunak
mark harper good morning to you and
thanks for being with us today on all
days uh so look we heard there from
those people in bristol just how
concerned they are i mean it's a big job
facing whoever gets into that door later
today
it is and i think the feedback there
from from those people from bristol uh
reflected it very well i think they
covered the the waterfront they covered
uh inflation and high energy prices but
they also covered that comment about the
nhs the important challenge facing
public services so it's a big entry uh
for whichever of the two candidates wins
the contest today
and whichever of the two i mean you're
supporting rishi sunak i mean it's all
over by the shouting isn't it or by the
speech that we can hear from this trust
later
well look liz trust was the favorite
throughout the the campaign but look
let's wait and see the result we're
going to hear the results i think at 12
30 uh today so look let's wait and see
there but whoever wins is going to have
to provide a big package of support to
help people like those people that you
just interviewed get through the winter
and as came through from that it
requires help to everybody but more help
targeted at those at the lower end of
the income distribution so that we can
get through and i've spent the summer
arguing that as has uh rishi sunak
and the argument doesn't seem to have
been as effective with members as um as
we think lis trust is in the leaders you
rightly point out and do you think her
package of measures
is going to be enough
well look i obviously don't know what
she's going to announce i listened
carefully to the interview that she gave
yesterday so she confirmed that there
would be a significant package of
support if she were to win the contest
today i think that will be necessary
it's very welcome that she said that and
obviously there does need to be a little
bit of time to to work through those
details and i think she said that she
would
lay out that package uh within a week of
becoming prime minister if that's what's
announced today
yeah and i guess that she's a changed
slightly from that uh line where she was
not gonna give handouts and you'll
welcome that as well now for the
conservative party then mark harper i
mean
how um optimistic are you that the party
can come back together after what's been
a very bruising uh campaign
well look i think this question about
bringing the conservative party back
together i think that's going to be a
big job um for the winner today um you
know obviously the election campaign's
been quite uh bruising you know but you
get people making those arguments during
campaigns the big question is about how
to bring the party together and i said
last week that the best way of doing
that it's a sign of strength actually is
for the winner of the contest to appoint
people to their cabinet from across the
party you know not just people that
supported them but from people from all
wings of the party if it is liz trust
that's what she said she wanted to do
during the campaign at the number of the
hustings that she did and i thought that
was very well supported by members of
the party i think party members in the
country
want the party uh in parliament to come
together and that can be best done i
think with a very broadly based cabinet
mr harper you will have seen the
reporting over the weekend of who's
already been sort of put forward to
being potential cabinet i mean it
includes people like ian duncan smith
jacob rees-mogg moving to business
quasi-quatting as treasury i mean is
that the the broad uh breadth of the
party that you want to see in this next
cabinet
well i don't know who's going to be
appointed i've seen all that speculation
in newspapers as well but there's often
we'll be happy with those names in those
positions there's often lots of
speculation i don't know who's going to
get appointed all i'm saying is from my
experience as a former government chief
whip in terms of managing the
parliamentary party if you've got a very
broadly based cabinet so accounting for
people not just people that supported
the winner then that's most likely to
have a unified and cohesive
parliamentary party and i think given
all of the challenges facing the winner
of this contest this winter i think that
will be the best way of a successful
outcome for the conservative party and
the conservative government
and in that uh sort of spirit if rishi
sunak was offered a job perhaps not the
job he's was had before and maybe not as
high-profile job do you think you should
take it in the spirit of unity of the
party
well i i can't speak for him i mean he
was asked this question and made the
point that you do have to if you're
going to be a member of the cabinet be
able to support the main thrust of the
government's policies so um you know
that would be a decision for him if that
is indeed what happens but i'm not going
to speak for him um but i think a
broadly based government that reflects
all views in the parliamentary party i
think is the best way of bringing the
party together
i mean is there a concern that if we
don't see rich in some kind of role and
you don't see the sort of broad base of
support across the party in a trust
cabinet that people could start working
against them we've already seen some
reporting of that this weekend in the
papers that there already are plots in
place china and sita
well look i don't think that would be
helpful i think it's much better if we
can all get behind the winner of the
contest today whoever that is
there's a huge challenge facing the
country
i think voters and indeed the party
members who've taken part in this
contest want to see the party come
together that responsibility i think
falls on the new
leader of the party and the new prime
minister to make uh good appointments
and then it's for people in the
parliamentary party also to get behind
them making the arguments and winning
over support from the public and putting
in place a package of support that's
necessary for the enormous challenge
that's facing uh households up and down
the country
yeah and the reporting of that package
that could be coming is the fact that
prices would be frozen i mean that is a
policy that uh the power companies have
put in place and of course very vocally
the labour party have been put calling
for for the past couple of weeks so is
that what the conservatives are going to
do just take another labor policy
well i don't know what the new prime
minister is going to set out i think for
me the most important thing is that we
put in place a significant package of
support to enable ordinary men and women
up and down the country to be able to
meet their energy
freeze on on prices as has been
suggested in some of the papers this
morning
well energy companies themselves set out
that as one possible way of dealing with
this um it has pros and cons uh direct
support to consumers has pros and cons
i don't know when they've looked at all
the numbers and all of the factors what
the new prime minister is going to come
out with the most important thing is
that people listening to this program
know that a significant package of help
is coming to enable them to get through
the winter and to be able to pay their
energy bills exactly how that happens is
the second order question the most
important thing is that significant
package of support is on its way
okay mark harper former chief whip and
support for youtube like appreciate your
time this morning thank you so much for
being with us pleasure